all right everybody we're back and guess
what coming up tomorrow night on this
show I'm thrilled actor Richard Harris
is going to be with us
that's very cool comedian Jake Johansen
and Vivica a fox has been with us so
check out that time
all right everybody Jeffrey Ross will be
here in just a minute but first let's
check in one more time with the talented
dogs of Westminster International dog
show now ladies and gentlemen right now
we have the winner of the Hound group
and this is very exciting this dog is an
insult comic that's right is an insult
comic very rare here we go thank you
very much
yes thank you very much it's great to be
here Conan O'Brien thank you for having
me Conan the Conan O'Brien show it's a
great show for me to poop on that's
right all right who do we have here
Conan who you got fur guest Siskel and
Ebert that's great doesn't everyone love
Siskel and Ebert a terrific oh yes you
know some people have their favorite
Siskel Ebert I think they're both great
for me to poop on all right no seriously
/ - you're terrific keeper you look
great you lost a lot of weight you know
that I tell you what you know what I
still wouldn't hump your leg
that's right okay okay no you're
terrific Ebert I dumped it but I dumped
your leg but I would pretend it was
Jeffrey Lyons leg you know what I'm
saying
[Applause]
that's okay get my hand everybody what
the hell is that and so a little more of
that dog than we wanted to see all right
all right we're gonna take a little
break when we come back Jeffrey Ross is
gonna be here he's a funny guy